bonsoir à vous deux
bonsoir bonsoir Patrice je suis pas sûr
de les chiffres le télétravail ça a
explosé là c'est une évidence 4% en 2016
32% 2021 et ça va en augmenter il y a
une tendance lourde les gens ont connu
ça veulent plus revenir comme avant si
je peux dire première question est-ce
que Maître Gravel est-ce que l'employeur
à tous les droits concernant le
télétravail le droit de dire oui vous
restez à la maison ou non vous revenez
dans l'état actuel des choses
l'employeur effectivement il doit être
gérance de déterminer
comme ça quels sont les prix villages
qui va accorder pour permettre à un
employé d'exercer ou non sur les lieux
du travail sa prestation de travail mais
il faut se souvenir monsieur roi caban
la pandémie le principe général c'est
que la prestation de travail
s'effectuait sur les lieux du travail
principe de base la pandémie ok un
nombre de chocs à l'égard de laquelle
autant les employeurs que les employés
que les syndicats tout le monde on a dû
s'adapter pour faire face à une
situation exceptionnelle c'est ça l'état
de situation ok mais si l'employeur
comme pour les fonctionnaires à Québec
on leur dit on leur dit vous revenez
trois jours ça c'est le droit de gérant
il aurait pu dire l'employeur va revenir
4 jours aussi mettre Gravette je vous
oublie pas monsieur Boyer mais ma
crevette
tout à fait je reviens au principe à la
règle de base la prestation de travail
de manière générale le naturellement
certains contrats prévoient des
aménagements particuliers mais si on
parle de manière générale la prestation
de travail sauf exception ça se réalise
sur les lieux du travail avec les outils
de travail de l'employeur donc
l'employeur le droit de dire vous
revenez Daniel Boyer est-ce que ça sera
de se lit dans le cas des fonctionnaires
fédéraux mais ce sera au centre de
plusieurs négociations collectives ou
des employés dit nous on veut obtenir ce
droit là de pouvoir rester en
télétravail
tout à fait je pense qu'on est rendu là
on est rendu au point où il faut
intégrer ces dispositions là dans nos
conventions collectives vous avez fait
mention le effectivement la pandémie a
fait en sorte qu'on est allé à vitesse
grand V concernant le télétravail et il
faut mettre ça dans l'information
collective vous savez on convenait au
début autour début
en 2021 je crois le comité consultatif
du travail d'Amed les patrons et des
organisations syndicales ont convenu que
en matière de télétravail on devrait
convenir d'un protocole ou d'une entente
cadre dans les milieux de travail donc
c'était un départ au départ au départ
qui disait que il fallait qu'il y ait
une entente ça peut pas aider j'entends
j'entends votre invité qui parle de
privilège
ça ne doit plus être un privilège au
moment ça doit être une condition de
travail négociée et c'est pas à ce point
c'est pas une condition qui s'applique à
tous on s'entend le plombier dans l'eau
on est dans la fonction publique
fédérale le plombier dans un centre de
détention il peut bien sûr pas faire son
travail à distance bien sûr
mais ça prend des critères objectifs et
d'autres décryptage subjectif je te le
donne à toi je te le donne pas à toi il
me semble que ça devrait l'objectif pour
permettre à tout le monde d'ailleurs les
études démontrent qu'il y a eu une
augmentation de la productivité
je crois que c'est selon les employés il
y a 90% qui disent qu'ils sont plus
efficaces ou aussi efficaces qu'avant
donc il y a 10% qui disent qu'ils le
sont moins c'est un peu évident mais je
suis pas sûr que c'est une étude qui est
totalement corroborée par tous les
employeurs Claude Gravel est-ce que ça
devrait être codifié effectivement dans
les conventions collectives est-ce que
ça va devenir
quelque chose de beaucoup plus précis
que simplement laisser ça aux droits de
gérance et que j'aime votre question
monsieur roi parce que dans le fond
c'est une réalité qui est en évolution
qui est en adaptation et comme n'importe
quel situation un mutation pour les
employeurs il faut faire preuve de
prudence non pas parce qu'on veut pas
mais davantage parce qu'une fois qu'on
aura consenti un droit et comme vous le
savez je pense que Monsieur Boyer va
être d'accord avec moi la marche en
arrière n'est pas possible ou est
difficilement possible donc c'est un peu
aussi vous savez les générations vont y
être pour beaucoup la génération à
laquelle j'appartiens a connu l'air du
fax et si on nous avait dit dans les
années 80 que éventuellement il y aura
une dématérialisation du lieu de travail
etc c'est de la science-fiction mais on
est dedans par contre quand je regarde
mes enfants qui sont au début de la
trentaine et certains collègues qui sont
dans la vingtaine eux ont ADN différent
de la nôtre et je suis convaincu qu'avec
le temps ces gens-là vont induire je
pense juste à l'expression que j'entends
souvent je suis capable où je suis
responsable ou enfin moi confiance qui
sont des concepts qui semblent émerger
beaucoup plus avec les jeunes
générations qu'avec la génération avec
laquelle j'appartiens naturellement à ce
qu'une généralité mais en perspective
également Daniel Boyer je veux remettais
le chapeau vous aviez à l'after
j'imagine que vous regarderiez les
négociations dans le secteur public
fédéral là avec beaucoup d'attention si
le syndicat arrive à faire entrer ça
dans la convention collective
ça va être ça va être un acquis qui va
servir à d'autres
qui va servir à d'autres mais déjà à
plusieurs tables de négociation là où il
y a du télétravail qui s'applique il y a
déjà des négociations nous on a donné de
la culture donnée de la formation au
négociateur à cet effet-là vous savez
nous c'est des cons ça fait partie des
conditions de travail on s'est battu
dans les années 80-90 lorsqu'il est
arrivé et puis
lorsqu'il est allumé les premiers
changements technologiques tu n'as pas
que des changements technologiques et
dispositions concernant des changements
technologiques fasse partie des
conventions collectives mais c'est la
même chose pour pour le télétravail
maintenant maintenant il y a des
avantages il y a certains inconvénients
aussi mais il y a de grands avantages
auprès des travailleurs on peut se
parler de la productivité mais on peut
sembler de conciliation travail famille
on peut se parler de la diminution des
gaz à effet de serre pas juste en terme
de vue pour la troisième ligne on l'a vu
pour le troisième
ok mais la question finalement parce que
oui ça va se négocier parce qu'on peut
pas non plus j'imagine vivre dans un
monde ce ne sont que les employés qui
décident si je rentre je rentre si je
rentre pas je rentre pas mettre Gravel
mais le marché va dicter aux employeurs
aussi une souplesse parce qu'ils
n'arrivent pas à obtenir des des
candidats pour entrer à l'intérieur les
candidats vont aller dans les
entreprises qui les laissent faire du
télétravail
vous savez monsieur roi j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour l'action syndicales puis
une réalité à l'heure actuelle c'est que
dans le fond
la relève nous employés dicte un peu la
manière dont les employeurs doivent se
comporter d'une part et d'autre part la
technologie puis parmi les facteurs
auxquels on est on est confronté à
l'heure actuelle vous avez des
entreprises américaines qui viennent ici
solliciter nos scientifiques nos
chercheurs et leur offre des emplois
tout en restant au Québec mais rémunérer
en dollars US et la dématérialisation du
lieu de travail un des conséquences de
toutes sortes sur la vie privée dont je
parle de productifié mais il y a pas
juste ça il y a l'aspect on va prendre
des symboles ne pas le plat à bonbons un
impact psychologique permettait la
machine à café permet des échanges alors
la dématérialisation du lieu de travail
amène aussi des phénomènes de solitude
d'isolement le problème de santé mentale
alors il y a pas juste des avantages il
y a aussi des inconvénients mais il y a
une chose qui est indéniable c'est qu'au
fil des années c'est les employeurs qui
récoltent davantage de responsabilités
et ça aussi ça doit être pris en compte
Daniel Boyer conclusion on peut plus
remettre ce que vous dites la pâte à
dents dans le tube il faut la gérer la
codifier on peut plus la remettre dans
on revient le repas à 3% de télétravail
non non pipi écoutez on a fait un
travail les patrons et les syndicats
ensemble au début de la pandémie parce
qu'il fallait s'asseoir il fallait
convenir de certaines dispositions il
faut amender certaines lois aussi qui
sont pas tout à fait au goût du jour loi
sur la santé sécurité la Loi sur les
normes les différentes législations il
faut les adapter à ce nouveau contexte
de travail là parce que il est là pour
rester là on sera pas cachée vous avez
tout à fait raison
si on a si on a du télétravail très bien
et et peut-être compenser ceux qui
doivent entrer dans des entreprises par
rapport à ceux qui n'entre pas bref
c'est ça c'est tout un domaine ça va
vous faire travailler mettre Gravel des
années des années merci beaucoup Daniel
Boyer expressant de FTQ mettre Gravel
avocat en droit du travail à la
prochaine
merci bonne soirée